[Music]  now your buddy Luke Bryan just announced  that he's joining Idol how do you think  he's gonna do in that platform well I  think people are gonna realize just how  how dumb he really is is that right  national television in an environment  where there's no script but you're also  gonna see what a great great  dude that guy I love Luke like a brother  I really do but he's just he's just dumb  he did you know well I don't know that  he asked for my advice but we had a lot  of conversations about him joining Idol  and and and I guess in a way you know I  gave him my thoughts on it and about how  I felt about it on behalf of him and in  fact I'm sure it's going to ABC right  I'm sure the executives at ABC are  really pissed at me right now for what  they probably had to pay him to get him  on that show good for you Luke  stick it to him he fought for everything  I thought I don't know but I'm sure I  mean Luke Bryan's not cheap yeah he  looks it but he's not  [Music]  you